so you may remember the mysterious metal  monolith you see it there  found in southern utah last week utah  highway patrol found it and no one knows  how it got there  just as mysterious utah officials say  this structure was removed yesterday  but take a look at this southwest  airlines responded to the disappearance  by saying  hey it's one of ours remember it was  over at the airport when you used to get  to fly all the time  southwest airlines says it needed it  back you can see it looks like the  things that they have in the airport  where you're standing in line  that's the tweet they put out another  user photoshopped the picture  southwest gave him credit and we all  lived happily ever after